BRETT HESTERBERG: First off,
thank you for walking over
from Moscone, many of you.
I'm very happy to be talking
today about Google's newest
managed database offering.
Cloud SQL, as of today,
is announcing support
for Postgres, which has
been one of our most
requested enhancements.
So it's nice to be
able to answer yes
to that question starting today.
What we're going to
talk about, of course,
is Cloud SQL for Postgres.
I'll do some focusing
on certain features that
are in the beta product.
And then we'll also look ahead.
Cloud SQL for Postgres
is a beta product,
which means we're
just getting started.
You're going to see us
deliver new features
during the beta program.
And I'll talk about
a few of those today.
After that, we'll
invite Tim Kelton,
who is co-founder and cloud
architect at Descartes Labs.
Tim has been an early adopter
of Cloud SQL for Postgres,
and generally has used
Postgres for many years
to build some really stunning
geospatial applications.
Tim will walk us
through how Descartes
is using Google Cloud to
build these applications,
and hopefully show
off one as well.
And then we'll get into
some next steps and things
that hopefully
you can take away.
Before we jump into all of that,
I have a few questions for you.
By show of hands, how many
of you in the audience
are developers?
So we got-- call it 2/3.
How about database
administrators?
How about reluctant
database administrators?
There's a few more hands.
And lastly, any managers
in the audience?
One brave soul, maybe two.
Thank you.
How many of you are
using Postgres today,
or use it frequently?
That's about half the room.
And how many of you
in the audience--
last question here for now--
are Cloud SQL users?
Not nearly as many.
OK, great.
Well, I think we're going
to have a little something
for everyone in the audience.
And we'll jump right in.
Let me start by saying
that Cloud SQL is
launching Postgres.
And when I say that, if you're
all on your laptops right now
and you go to Cloud
Console, click on Cloud SQL.
You won't see Postgres
get in the Console.
We're launching it
as we speak, which
means some of you,
today and tomorrow,
will begin to see
that in your Console.
Many of you, over
this coming weekend,
will see it in your Console.
And all of you, by
early next week,
will see Postgres
in your Console,
and be able to create instances.
That said, all of you today,
with the CLI or an API,
can create a Cloud SQL for
Postgres instance right now.
So, based on the
response from the room,
I don't have to go into
the merits of Postgres.
But I think many of you
using Postgres right now see
that it's a powerful open
source relational database.
Really, a vibrant open
source community backing it,
with many years of
active development.
And in addition to strong
standards compliance,
I think one of the most
unique features about Postgres
is the fact that
it is extensible.
And we'll be talking
today specifically
about one extension,
PostGIS, which
adds powerful object
or geospatial object
support to Postgres.
So where does Cloud SQL fit
in Google's fairly broad
and growing database portfolio?
On this slide, rightmost,
you see Google's data
warehousing product, BigQuery--
again, rightmost column.
We store objects in
Cloud Storage or GCS.
We have non-relational NoSQL
databases in Cloud Datastore
and BigTable.
Finally, you get to
the relational space,
where Cloud SQL lives
along with Spanner.
And if you haven't
taken a look at Spanner
yet, or been to
some of the talks
about Spanner going
on at the conference,
I would encourage you to do so.
And then furthest
over on the left,
we have our in memory products
in Memcache for App Engine.
So you get kind of a feel for
where Cloud SQL is, broadly,
in the database portfolio.
The thing I'll note
about Cloud SQL
is that Cloud SQL
delivers standard MySQL
and now Postgres databases.
Which means if you have
an application running
with Postgres today,
with few exceptions
your application will run
immediately with Cloud SQL.
We're not offering Postgres
compatibility layers,
we're offering standard
Postgres and standard MySQL.
The other thing I'll say about
Cloud SQL is it is not a DBA.
We do our best to offload
the more mundane database
administration tasks--
installing databases,
patching them,
setting up backups--
but we are not a
DBA In the sense
that Cloud SQL won't
optimize queries, et cetera.
As we look at running databases
in Google Cloud, or on-prem,
or elsewhere, I think
the thing you'll
hear me repeat in
this presentation
is Cloud SQL is a
managed database service.
It's important, I
think, to distinguish
what exactly that means.
So let's do this by just
taking a look at what
it takes to run a database.
And we'll start with
the hardware layer.
Folks in the audience
who are running on-prem
are thinking today
about power and cooling.
Even if you're
not, even if you've
gone to a co-lo or a hosting
provider or a cloud vendor,
I would encourage you to think
about server maintenance.
Here in Google Cloud, part
of our server maintenance
is live migration
with Compute Engine.
Cloud SQL benefits
from that feature.
And if you aren't
aware of it, there's
been a few great blog posts put
out by the Compute Engine team
on live migration.
Obviously, server maintenance,
whether you are maintaining
your servers or not,
has major implications
for your application stack.
So then we look at the operating
system on top of the servers.
And this is where we
reach a fork in the road.
This is the first place
where if I'm deciding,
should I self-host a database
on Google Cloud, for example,
or go to a managed database
products like Cloud SQL?
We start to see some
real differences.
If you're self-managing
a database,
you're going to install
your operating system,
you're going to maintain
it with patches, et cetera.
Cloud SQL, you won't see
the operating system.
We maintain it for you.
It's not even exposed.
Of course, when you're
self-managing a database,
you're going to do
the database install.
You're going to patch
it, keep it up to date.
You're going to set
up database backups.
In the Cloud SQL or
the managed world,
we're doing that,
again, for you.
We're turning on automatic
backups if you'd like us to.
We're pruning those
as we go along.
And we've also taken care of
the software patches, et cetera.
Lastly, we'll look at
the advanced features,
high availability.
If you're self-managing,
to get high availability,
you are setting up replication
between Postgres databases,
for example.
You've built tooling
that monitors
the health of these databases.
And you are alerting so
that you can manually
failover in the
case of some outage,
or you've built additional
scripts, et cetera,
to failover automatically.
In the managed database
space, with Cloud SQL,
Cloud SQL takes care of
high availability for you
in that it sets up
the replication.
We do the monitoring and
actually trigger the failovers.
The other thing here is,
in the managed world,
you are backed by Google's team.
In the self-managed world,
you are backing the database
availability itself.
Last item on the
slide is scaling.
In a self-managed
world, you decide
when to scale up, when to scale
out, and you implement those.
In the managed world--
want to make special note here.
Cloud SQL helps you
scale more easily.
We help you scale up easily,
help you scale out easily.
But unlike other database
products in our portfolio,
Cloud SQL does not auto scale.
So it's up to you still,
as an administrator,
to decide it's time to scale
up, or it's time to scale out.
One thing that we shouldn't
forget is monitoring.
And monitoring goes beyond
just application-level kind
of monitoring,
Stackdriver for example.
And this can be something
like, I want to make sure
that my slow query logs get to
Pub/Sub or to Cloud Logging,
for easy ingestion by third
party apps like Splunk,
for example.
With a managed service,
a lot of this plumbing
is set up for you.
Self-managed, it's not.
Now, I'm the Cloud
SQL product manager,
so obviously I
have some bias here
in terms of managed databases.
My point here is not to
say that one is necessarily
better than the other.
You all are making
tradeoffs during your day.
You're deciding,
I'm going to spend
more time in this piece
of my technology stack,
to make sure it is customized
to exactly what I want.
And as a trade-off, I'm going
to spend more time managing
that piece of the stack.
I think the decision between
self-managing databases
and a managed database service
like cloud SQL, is very much
that.
You will lose customization
or flexibility
when you go to
the managed world,
but you gain all
these offloading
of what we call mundane tasks.
The self-managed world,
you can tune Postgres
to your heart's content, but
you are managing that database,
and managing its up time.
So hopefully that
gives you a good sense
for how we break
down the difference
between self-managing
and managing databases.
And again, I'm happy to say
that Cloud SQL now gives you
the option to do
this with Postgres.
So let me highlight just
a few features for you.
As a starting point,
Cloud SQL for Postgres
offers large instance
sizes, up to 32 cores
and more than 200
gigabytes of RAM.
You can see in the
screenshot here
we are showing the
fact that we're
using custom VMs as the
underlying mechanism to Cloud
SQL, which means
you get granularity
with respect to number
of CPU cores, size
of RAM on your instance type.
The other thing I'll note is,
we have inexpensive development
instances.
Our smallest instances start
at less than $10 a month.
So you can get going with
Postgres very affordably,
for example.
Next feature I'll
talk about is storage.
I think it's intuitive for us
to scale a database in terms
of CPUs and RAM.
A little less intuitive
is scaling performance
in terms of storage.
And the thing I'll note
here is that at Google, we
scale storage performance
by scaling capacity.
So if you add capacity,
you get more performance.
What you're seeing here, built
into the Cloud SQL instance
creation form that will be
coming live to your console
soon, is--
we see the performance
calculator on the bottom.
And what it's
showing you is this
is the performance
level you can expect
based on the number of
CPU cores you've selected,
and the size of your storage.
In this case, you
can see I am not
maxing out the IOPS I could
get out of my instance.
If I were to add
capacity, you would
see that slider bar ratchet up
all the way to, in this case,
25,000 IOPS.
There's a small checkbox next to
a one-liner in our Create form
that I think is
really important.
And it's our auto
storage increase feature.
So when you check
this box, you can
see it enable the
auto storage increase.
That tells Google, you deal
with my storage capacity.
As I get near my 10-gigabyte
limit, or 400-gigabyte limit
in this case, increase
the storage capacity
for me automatically.
And the nice thing about Google
persistent storage is that we
can increase the storage--
whether capacity, performance,
both--
as a hot operation.
You don't take
your database down.
So if you check that box, you
leave the storage capacity
management to us.
We will automatically grow
your storage as you need it,
while your database is running.
Next feature is backups
that are included
with Cloud SQL for Postgres.
You can enable automatic
backups, which get taken daily.
You tell us what time of day
you want those backups taken.
We automatically prune those.
After seven days, we'll get
rid of your oldest backup
and take the newest.
So you get a rolling
seven-day automatic backup.
You can also take
on-demand backups.
These are manual backups
that you control yourself.
You decide when to take them.
And you decide how
to retain them.
If you want to retain one for a
year, or three years, or seven
years, you can do so.
We keep them as
long as you want.
With respect to maintenance--
I talked about maintenance
in that decision
between self-managing
and managing database.
With respect to maintenance,
we offer a maintenance window.
You tell us day of
week and time of day,
and we'll make sure that
any maintenance we do
is performed in that window.
You also tell us
maintenance timing.
So if you have two Postgres
database instances in a given
project, you might say, I would
like my development instance
to be maintained or updated
before my production instance.
And you can use the
maintenance timing field here,
which is earlier and later,
to decide that my development
instance should be updated
before my production instance.
And when you do that,
you get yourself
about a week of difference
between these two things.
So something on
the earlier track
will get updated one week before
something on the later track,
is our general guidance
on maintenance timing.
The last point I'll
mention here is extensions.
And I think part of
Postgres' uniqueness
and its power is in its
extension ecosystem.
We've included a handful of
extensions at the beta launch.
We expect this list
to grow over time,
and we'll look
for your feedback.
The extension we wanted to make
sure we got into the product
for launch is PostGIS.
It's one of the most frequently
used extensions for Postgres,
and it's always used
by folks like yourself
who are interested in
geospatial applications.
So what's next?
I told you that this
is a beta product
and we're just getting started.
It means you're going to
see us land large features
during the beta period.
So what's not included today?
Things around replication
are not included today.
So for example, we don't
yet offer high availability,
nor do we offer read scale
out with read replicas.
Those things are coming.
We offer backups and
recovery, but we don't yet
offer point in time recovery.
Again, that's another
one that's coming.
And from a connectivity
point of view,
today Cloud SQL for Postgres
supports connections
from Compute Engine, from App
Engine, flexible environment,
which just went GA, from
Container Engine, or generally
from any client that supports
a standard Postgres connector.
That said, we don't yet
support connectivity
from Cloud Functions, which was
announced at this conference.
Nor do we get
support connectivity
from App Engine Standard.
So you've got a few
things to look forward
to as part of this beta period,
and to keep in mind as you
start to use the product.
So I have another set
of questions for you.
And I will ask you
all, by show of hands--
and we'll be on the honor
system, you get one vote.
If you're telling
us what to do next,
which of these five features
is most important to you?
So again, honor system,
you get one vote.
How many of you say,
I want you, Google,
to do high availability next?
Got about-- call
it 1/3 of the room.
All right, how
about read replicas?
This is read scale out?
I'm counting Tim's vote as well.
Another 1/3 of the room.
Connectivity from
App Engine Standard?
One brave soul.
Cloud Functions connectivity?
A couple of folks.
A couple of folks are
excited about that one.
And lastly, point
in time recovery?
I'm going to assume all of you
are worried about recovery,
but are just not voting it
above these other features.
OK, so it looks like
the replication features
were our hottest commodity.
I appreciate that feedback.
And if you do have questions as
we go along, keep them in mind.
Tim and I are going to
leave some time at the end,
and we've got mics
so that we'll be
able to answer your questions.
So, it's one thing to
talk just about a product.
I think where this
gets exciting is
how you put a product
like this together
with other technologies to
build a great application.
And I'm excited to say
that Tim Kelton, who
is the co-founder of Descartes
Labs, is here with us today.
Tim and Descartes Labs
have been an early adopter
of Cloud SQL for Postgres.
They participated in a
private alpha program.
Tim and the team at
Descartes have put together
Postgres with PostGIS
and a number of products
in Google Cloud to build
some outstanding geospatial
applications.
And I ask you all to
join me in welcoming Tim.
TIM KELTON: Thanks, Brett.
Today, I'd like to share with
you how some of the geospatial
features that Brett
just mentioned
are helping us at Descartes
Labs focus on the really
hard problems we're trying
to solve, and less on the day
to day managing and
scaling of infrastructure.
So, what are those
hard problems?
Descartes Labs applies
machine learning and AI
to global satellite
and aerial imagery
to see how the Earth
changes every day.
And our goal is to help
customers quantify and predict
how those changes
will affect them.
And our first products
looked at things like,
how much food are we
producing in North America?
And we built a platform
on Google Cloud,
initially to answer those
questions such as agriculture.
But we've since found as
a range of applications
in areas such as
security and trading,
but also in supply
chain and logistics.
So, Descartes Labs was
founded in December of 2014.
We are Silicon Valley backed,
and we have Silicon Valley
veteran leadership.
And that's where
the story changes.
We're not the stereotypical
Silicon Valley startup.
Myself and the rest
of the founding team
were researchers,
engineers, and scientists
high up in the mountains of
northern New Mexico at Los
Alamos National Laboratory.
And there we focused on
areas such as deep learning,
remote sensing, and large-scale
high performance computing.
And today we have
nearly 30 employees,
and relevant to this talk,
we have no DBAs on staff.
So, how did we
find Google Cloud?
It's a little bit different
story than maybe typically.
As an early-stage startup, we
kind of just go spend millions
and millions of dollars
buying satellite imagery,
and the Earth Engine team
at Google actually provided
a public data set called--
from NASA-- called Landsat.
And Landsat was
launched in 1973,
and has been continuously
observing the Earth since then.
And so that is
available natively
on Google Cloud Storage,
in a Cloud Storage bucket.
You can just simply GSUtil
LS and see all of the imagery
there.
So we started, in the early
months of the company,
started pulling imagery
down to VMs on Google Cloud,
and building small-scale
models over very
limited geographical regions and
over very small time windows.
Trying to do something like
forecast food production
in the United States.
It was quickly apparent
that wouldn't work.
So we needed to scale
up our processing.
Coming from places
like Los Alamos, where
you have high performance
supercomputing
and access to a
lot of resources,
you're not necessarily
instantly confident
that the Cloud
will actually scale
to the levels you need it to.
And very quickly,
we knew we would
need to use models that would
cover large geographic regions
such as the entire
United States,
and would see many, many
years of crops growing.
You can think,
here in California,
like two years ago,
what was the story?
It was all droughts
and bleak water levels.
And this year we have reservoirs
dramatically overflowing.
So to build accuracy
in these models,
we needed a large window.
And so just a few
months into the company,
we were able to scale
up on Google Cloud
our code to process that entire
petabyte Landsat and MODIS
imagery to process all of
that in just over 15 hours
on 30,000 virtual cores.
And that's the power of having
this data natively on the Cloud
right next to Compute.
And, like I said, coming from
places with high performance
computing, what we are
so pleasantly surprised
with was not just that we were
able to get lots of cores,
but also that storage
was able to scale
with our needs and networking.
All of those need
to scale uniformly
to actually scale up and process
that amount of data really
quickly.
So, once we had processed
all of this data,
we were able to build
models over much
larger geographic regions such
as the whole United States,
and see daily changes as
new satellite imagery comes
in every single day.
In 2015, we had
our first models.
And when they got
announced on Bloomberg,
they actually moved the
market a few percent.
And we were all kind of
surprised and excited.
And then later in 2016,
as most people that
work in machine
learning are constantly
trying to improve the
accuracy of the models,
we improved our models.
We also started
working with customers
on larger geographic
regions around the Earth,
and on adding multiple, more--
multiple new crops.
Additionally, we
now actually release
our models, what we're
predicting as far as food
supply, on a mobile app.
So later in 2016,
on Google Cloud,
the Earth Engine team
made a second dataset
publicly available, again
natively on Cloud Storage.
So this is just there.
You can go in your browser--
on your command line and
GSUtil LS this directory.
And that's from the
European Space Agency.
That's the Sentinel 2 data set.
So this is petabytes of
imagery that are actually
stored in Google Cloud, and
Google is paying the bill
for hosting this imagery.
And so you can
quickly just start
working on the actual problem
you're trying to solve.
Today, I want to share with
you a little more information
about the platform we built
on top of Google Cloud.
And I want to show you
a product that we just
launched on Tuesday called
Geovisual Search that we've
built on top of our platform.
So, just a high-level diagram of
what our platform consists of.
As I already mentioned,
we have various data sets
from NASA and the US--
NASA, European Space Agency,
a number of other public data
sets.
And it's great when they
just live in the cloud.
But a lot of these we
actually need to pull in.
And the sensors
on satellites that
have been launched over
basically a decade or more
vary tremendously.
They vary in the amount of
light bands that they capture.
They vary in the sensor
technology that's used.
And our end goal is to make
a really common imagery API
that we can quickly have
our machine learning teams
have a nice Python API around.
And no matter which
set of imagery,
or which layers of
light, that it will
be a really uniform experience.
And so we have--
so you can think of
things more like a Python
API or a Jupyter Notebook
kind of similar to Datalab.
So our processing-- we
start with ingesting
all of this imagery.
And we have to do things like co
register the imagery for really
accurate alignment.
We have to convert it
to standard projections.
Things like removing clouds.
Here in San
Francisco, and I'm not
talking about
compute clouds, I'm
talking about overhead
clouds which in San Francisco
happen quite a bit.
Correct for shadows, adjust
for camera angles, angles
of the sun,
calibrate the sensors
against their neighbors,
atmospheric reflectance.
All of these things
have to happen
in our initial
processing pipeline.
And that happens
on Compute Engine,
using primarily managed
instance groups.
And we heavily leverage
the preemptable instances
to cut down on
costs in that case,
because it's very embarrassingly
parallel workload.
So then, we have two directions
from our processing pipeline
where data goes.
Our imagery, or what
we call raster data,
those are the pixels.
That gets stored natively.
I think, as Brett had
a slide, that gets
stored on Cloud Storage.
We know that Cloud Storage
we will not run out of space.
We're expecting to have
nearly 15 petabytes of imagery
by the end of this year.
We know that it will scale.
We know that we
can throw thousands
of cores processing against
it, and it will handle that.
And it's nothing
we have to manage.
So all of our compressed
imagery gets stored.
And this is on the
left side of the chart.
And then, those services are
available via microservices
sitting on top of
Container Engine, where
we can query and pull down
those images really quickly.
The second part of our
imaging processing pipeline
is more of the vector data.
As we see each scene,
we capture pieces
of information about
that scene and we
use Pub/Sub to persist that
information into a PostGIS
database.
These are things we
need to spatially query.
And so PostGIS enables us
a mechanism to do that,
and Cloud SQL supporting
PostGIS starts giving us
more of the freedom to not
do things like install GOS
and GDOL and Proj4J, and Lib
to XML, just to get things
into a geospatial database.
And so those are more of
what we consider vector data.
Things like polygons and
points, or given points of data
that we might use to train
our machine learning models.
Say this given
geographic region,
what do we see the values
at that given time?
And then try and train the
models to correlate with that.
So we have many sources of
data that we store in PostGIS.
Things like public data
from maybe the US Department
of Agriculture.
But also private data sets
sometimes from customers
as well.
So then, both of
those come together.
We host many, many
micro services.
Again, on top of either
managed instance groups
or on top of GKE.
And then that's where
we are able to do
image searching, image rasters,
location based searches,
and build models on top of that.
And finally, one last theme.
In the last six
months, I would say,
we've started
adopting Stackdriver.
Stackdriver provides a nice,
uniform way to do logging.
And we're gradually using
the alerting features more
and more.
And we can use that on things
like preemptable instances,
which come and go.
Things like logging
is quite challenging
to figure out good
solutions for.
But we can also tie that into
Cloud Pub/Sub, to Cloud SQL,
and to GKE, and we have
a really common way
of querying logs to look for
errors or latency problems,
or just diagnose code.
So what types of models
do we actually produce?
This is a little
bit more information
on the agricultural models
I mentioned earlier.
And we started doing this
in 2015, just a few months
into our company.
How is this done traditionally?
The US Department of
Agriculture will send surveys.
And they send thousands
of surveys out
to individual farmers a few
times during the growing season
to get progress on the
actual growth of crops.
And then they aggregate
the surveys back,
and finally release a number
and then the market moves.
How do we do it?
We have a quite
different approach.
We pull in about four
quadrillion pixels.
So you can think of billions
and billions of iPhone photos.
And we see every
field, everywhere
in the Earth, every single day.
And those are inputs
into our models
to basically predict how
much food will be produced
at the end of the year.
And so as I said, we've iterated
on those models many times.
And you can see
in this graph, we
can show that we not only
are more accurate than the US
Department of Agriculture, but
we get that information much
earlier.
And we can see how things
like a big weather event,
like a hailstorm in Iowa--
what was the actual
effect of that?
I should say, in
2017, our models
will now be backtested
over the last 13 years.
So we can go back 12 years
ago, or five years ago,
and say, how did the model
perform given this weather
parameter?
One really exciting
advance is, we're now
extending the use of
these models to do
things like try and
detect early indications
of a famine outbreak.
So this is something
in North Africa,
you can think of things
like political instability
that occur from food shortage,
getting aid to places faster,
and the amount of
lives you can save.
It's really exciting
to be a part of that.
So next, I'd like to
show you what we just
released on Tuesday, something
called Geovisual Search.
And Geovisual Search extends
on top of the machine learning
platform that I was
showing you, being
able to do geospatial
queries over windows of time
and pull together multiple
different bands of light.
Not just always
human-visible bands,
such as red, green, blue, but
also things like infrared.
And build models, and
iterate on models,
to see things that you could
never actually humanly hire
enough people to see.
As part of that, we
need training data.
And we have many sources
of training data,
like I mentioned before.
One of those that's open
source is OpenStreetMaps.
We can use a area
such as OpenStreetMaps
to train in a given
geographic location.
What are we actually
seeing in these images?
And then we use
TensorFlow to build models
that, as we processed our
imagery through there,
we determine various
signatures of each scene
all across the globe.
And then we try and see where
else in trillions and trillions
of pixels across the
entire Earth, where
else do we see similar items?
So this is, again, we use
Pub/Sub in this scenario
to persist that data.
But this time, we're persisting
the model results out
into BigTable.
And then finally
using Container Engine
to serve the APIs and
the front end interface.
So, as part of this
talk, I thought
I would just
quickly show you one
problem I would have
on traditionally
using this approach.
Again, things like
OpenStreetMaps.
I'm just trying to
train a data set.
It's a public open
source data set.
Sometimes it's accurate,
sometimes it's not.
Sometimes our models that
we'll train out of that
aren't going to produce
that good of results,
and we'll need to try
a different approach.
So the end goal is not to build
a long production database
always.
It's to get a geospatial
data set in there
so we can use it for
training, and then
move on to the next models.
So, this is-- I don't
know if anyone here
has had fun with OpenStreetMaps
and using the tool
OSM to PGSQL.
It's an importer
tool that lets you
import all of OpenStreetMaps
into a PostGIS
compatible database.
So, as you might be able
to scroll down and see
all these fun messages, after
a few hours of importing I
took a 50-gig compressed
OpenStreetMaps file,
and it's a 50-gig
compressed XML file.
So it's really hard to
guess exactly how big that's
going to be in PostGIS.
And all of a sudden,
I get to the spot
where I have no disk
space left on device
and I've wasted my time.
And I need to now make a
bigger VM with a larger disk
and try this again.
And maybe I've guessed
right the second time.
But that's not that different
than getting requirements.
I don't know if any of you have
asked for requirements early
on in a project, and
you've received input.
And either you never,
ever, used all the space
that was asked for,
or you basically
started way too small,
and your project
became wildly
successful, and you
needed to import all these other
data sets into the database.
So, one of the features Brett
mentioned was the auto growth.
So here's an example of--
by clicking the Auto Growth,
or selecting that in the API,
we could start with a 10-gig
disk and instantly grow.
And we grew, over a
few hours, to 380--
it looks like 387 gigs.
And the awesome
part about this was
I just am paying for the
amount of storage I actually
need at that given time.
I'm not overestimating,
I'm not underestimating,
and I know it can grow.
And we're really excited about
things like read replicas
and high availability as well.
Especially applying that to
micro services, which sometimes
start really small,
but then get really,
really useful as
you add features.
So at this point, I would like
to switch over to the demo.
And it looks like I need
to type my password.
And I would like
to show you what
we built on top of Cloud SQL,
PostGIS, BigTable, Pub/Sub.
This is San Francisco.
This is using the
national aerial imagery.
We are storing all of this data.
We are not attaching
PD Disks to VMs.
Instead, we're using
managed instance groups
which are natively
reading Cloud Storage
with a super fast layer.
So this is all of the US,
and this is all native Cloud
Storage, reading
to those imagery.
So, as I mentioned
before-- and by the way,
if you're really interested
in how we did all of that,
our CTO will be giving a
talk this afternoon at 5:20,
and that's IO242,
and we'll talk all
about the file system
and Cloud Storage
as a scalable file system.
So in this example, I
can look for a number
of different
signatures that we've
trained TensorFlow models on.
Some of the examples, we have
a center pivot irrigation.
Here's floating top oil storage
tanks, orchards, marinas.
And in this example, I'm going
to look at wind turbines.
And what we do is, we
slice this entire layer.
This layer is specifically
aerial imagery.
And this is only of
the United States.
But then we have other layers
at different resolutions
and different bands of
light, such as the Landsat
I mentioned earlier.
And also Planet, who will
be giving the keynote--
part of the keynote tomorrow.
And we can search over
all of those layers,
we slice up into tiny squares
and we write a signature.
And this is all done
through TensorFlow models.
And then, if we
click on this area,
I can see all of the
different places on this map
that we've found a
visually similar object.
So here, I can scroll
in and I can see,
and it looks like we've found
visually similar wind turbines.
I can click over to
somewhere in California,
and again, I can
find wind turbines.
Pretty interesting use case
is center pivot irrigation.
And again, I'll look
over all of the Earth.
And you think, how many people?
I could hire 10,000
people and have them just
looking at scenes every
day as they come in.
They would probably commit
suicide or something else,
but in this case, we
can easily use things
like machine learning to scale
up to levels that you really
never could humanly.
So here, we've found
more crop circles.
And finally, just an
example on Planet.
Planet's a really neat data set.
Planet is not launching
hundreds of millions
of dollar large
satellites the way
NASA would have traditionally
launched satellites.
They're instead using really
small, commodity-based cube
sats.
And they'll see the
whole Earth once a day
at three meters for each pixel.
And so with Planet,
we have a number
of things in this China
dataset that we've trained on.
And here's one example
of solar farms in China.
And I can look
everywhere in China,
and I can see different places
in China that are solar farms.
And here is all
the other results
that we found that are the
top 500 most similar searches.
So if I could switch
back to the presentation.
So, where we're going with
this is things like eventually
being able to see, in 2011 I
didn't see a wind turbine here.
And now as we've
brought new imagery,
we all the sudden see
things like, oh, there's
a wind turbine.
This is really neat
type of capability.
So as we're streaming
in data from all
of these different satellites,
looking down at the Earth,
we're constantly feeding
those back into models
and aggregating results that
help our customers really
answer hard problems.
Just two other
real brief examples
of the types of
scenarios our platform
has to adjust for, and how
there's not just one solution.
In this example, with red,
green, and blue imagery,
it's quite hard to
actually pick out
where the wind
turbines actually are.
However, we can use, from
the European Space Agency's
Sentinel 1 satellite,
there's something
called synthetic aperture
radar on the satellite.
And we collect this
globally, and--
excuse me-- synthetic aperture
radar emits and detects radar
signals.
Those radar signals can
pass through clouds.
They can even work at night.
And it gives you a measurement
of almost like a height
measurement on the ground.
And you can see these
vertical lines up and down,
showing all of those wind
turbines in that field.
More on the agriculture side.
Here it's quite
challenging to actually see
the Ove River in Russia.
You can see it's kind of dark,
and there's definitely an area
that you think the river
and vegetation's there.
However, if we switch over
to red edge bands that
are more like infrared,
you can see the river
and the vegetation is
highlighted in really, really
bright yellow.
And then you can
see water channels.
So there's not one solution.
Our platform needed
to be able to handle
a lot of different types of
machine learning questions
that we were asking of it.
And not every problem needs
the same bands of light
or the same types of
temporal cadences.
And finally, I'd
just like to wrap up.
Where we're going
at Descartes is
moving on to using things,
taking this platform that we've
built for these
internal use cases,
and making this
commercially available.
So we have all of
this imagery available
that's been cleaned
and co-registered
and has a really nice
API to do analysis
across many different sources
just with the basic Python API.
And we hope that showing
you these types of things,
you have ideas of scenarios
I haven't shown you.
And you would like to maybe
build models on your own,
without having to go through
all of these hassles.
So we're hoping to make that--
right now, this is
in private beta.
But we're hoping to eventually
open that up to the public
later this year.
So email us at hello@descartes
if you're interested.
And I think with that, I'll
turn it back over to Brett.
BRETT HESTERBERG:
Really cool stuff.
I loved the demo.
It's truly finding
needles in a haystack.
OK, so let's talk about next
steps and wrap up a little bit.
As I mentioned at the top,
we have beta availability
of Postgres on Cloud
SQL starting very soon.
All users will have
access early next week.
Watch for more features coming.
I got your feedback today.
You want HA, you
want replication.
Watch out for big features
coming over the beta period.
A couple of points on
our partner ecosystem.
Cloud SQL has a partner
ecosystem established.
We've added new partners for
the Postgres launch today.
You see a number of business
intelligence software
that have already been certified
with Cloud SQL for Postgres.
And if you're thinking
to yourselves,
I've got a data
transformation problem,
or I want to understand how
I can get my data from where
it is today into Cloud
SQL for Postgres,
the list of ETL partners
is a great place to start.
All of these partners are on
the Cloud SQL partner ecosystem
website.
And they're ready to help you
with Cloud SQL for Postgres.
A few presentation picks.
Tim mentioned IO242, which
is happening later today.
I encourage you all to
attend that this afternoon.
We're on day two of Next.
You've got day three tomorrow.
First pick on this slide
is a bit self-serving.
We've got another
Cloud SQL presentation.
This one is focused
on optimizing
performance and availability
in our MySQL product.
So if you want to go deep
into database tuning,
see what we do as
Cloud SQL, see where
you can get the configuration
that we actually
use in Cloud SQL to
tune our performance,
come to that talk
tomorrow morning at 11:20.
I'm also excited about
building high performance
micro services with Kubernetes.
And a look at BigTable,
specifically low latency
applications with respect
to personalized content.
BigTable, again, is our
NoSQL database product.
So a few presentation
picks if you're still
finalizing what you're going
to go see this afternoon
and into tomorrow.
All of you should take a look
at Cloud SQL for Postgres.
By attending this conference,
you received Cloud Credits.
You can get additional
credits by signing up
for the free trial link
that you see on the slide.
Use those credits.
Get familiar with
Cloud SQL for Postgres.
Give us feedback.
And like Tim, hopefully offload
a little bit of your work
so you can build a great
application as well.
With that, thank you all for
your time this afternoon.